la cafet vous la savez vous que faisait
entrer dans la surface ne le sont pas
tous la même si je ne suis pas capable
mais je ne vous connais pas est un
écolier bon jérémy monnier
vous n'y a pas dit que nous
n'accueillons pas les bardes et le
satanisme à ce chapitre il faut être
beaucoup plus courtois j'ai repris mon
cher et bill d'être un peu plus place
avec notre hôte la politesse apporte une
plus-value
il vous rendra bien mais ça puisse aller
dimanche à emmen soyez moins triviale
c'est capital
il le mérite est apparemment pas de
rente et après la route séparant pilier
chez elle mardi
[Musique]
là
attali
ce
[Musique]
bonjour à tous nouvelle vidéo alors
aujourd'hui on va s'attaquer quand même
un monument karl marx je ne vais pas
vous parler du capital parce que vous
voyez mon signé et seulement ici ça fait
trois ans que je lis et je suis toujours
par yves à bout alors j'étais un peu
rassuré parce que j'ai entendu que sur
france culture et à beaucoup de gens qui
essaient de le lire et qui arrivaient
pas et même de très grands noms et de
très grands intellectuels
je ne vous parlerai pas non plus d'un
autre bouquin un peu plus je veux dire
sulfureux un peu plus dans la mouvance
de karl marx l'idéologue qui est le
manifeste du parti communiste
non aujourd'hui je vais pas vous parler
de quelques feuilles c'est la préface en
fait d'un ouvrage de karl marx qui
s'appelle contribution à la critique
d'économie politique et qui est paru en
c'est à dire quand même quelques années
avant le capital qui lui est publié pour
le premier livre en 1867
mais ce qui est assez hallucinant c'est
qu'ici on retrouve voyez j'ai simplement
flotter sur le texte se trouve assez
facilement sur le net je vous mettrais
de toute façon le lien en descriptions
j'ai simplement flux haute et ce qui est
vraiment essentiel et ses éléments
c'est la quintessence le fil rouge de
tout l'analyse marxiste de la société et
en particulier de la société capitaliste
je trouve que c'est très important pour
des élèves du secondaire d'avoir en tête
le modèle finalement le modèle
d'analystes utilise marx pour comprendre
la société et son évolution est
d'ailleurs marx le dit lui même parce
qu'il le dit ici au début du texte
le résultat général auquel j'arrivais
servi de fil conducteur à mes études
peut brièvement se formuler ainsi nourri
si karl marx nous propose vraiment le
fil conducteur et de quoi est fait ce
fil conducteur ce fil conducteur va nous
permettre de comprendre ce qu'est le
matérialisme et en fin de vidéo vous
saurez c'est quoi une vision
matérialiste c'est quoi le matérialisme
historique comme on l'appelle alors pour
marx tout commence avec ce qu'on appelle
les forces productives les forces
productives c'est à la fois des
techniques d
machine des savoir faire et bien sûr des
hommes qui vont manipuler qui vaut
mettre en action ses savoir faire et ses
techniques et donc on peut bien
comprendre que pour marx il y à un
progrès dans la société dans l'évolution
de la société dans l'évolution même de
l'organisation la société devrais je
dire pour être plus précis et donc le
progrès va amener au fil du temps des
nouvelles techniques et ce sont ces
techniques et le travail
l'appropriation finalement par le
travail que les hommes en font qui vont
déterminer tout le reste
alors c'est quoi tout le reste mais
c'est tout toute la société va être
conditionné déterminé par ça donc on a
des techniques on a des façons
finalement de produire des choses au
sein la société alors ça peut être la
société antique la société féodale la
société asiatique la société primitive
et chaque force productive va créer va
engendrer des rapports de production et
les rapports de production sait les
relations entre les hommes qui sont
telles qu'elles sont déterminées par les
forces productives
on aura dans ses rapports de production
mais simplement les relations que
peuvent avoir les différentes classes
sociales mais aussi la distribution de
la richesse
comment ça se fait au sein de ces
différentes classes sociales
tout ça c'est ce qu'on appelle les
rapports de production
donc j'ai des forces productives qui
vont déterminer des rapports de
production et ses rapports de production
s es forces productives forme finalement
une matrice économique
ce que certains appellent
l'infrastructure économique qui va
déterminer le reste de la société et le
reste de la société c'est à la fois les
structures politiques les façons de voir
les façons de penser le droit les
religions et toutes ces choses là
marx nous le dit très clairement que les
formes juridiques politiques religieuses
artistique ou philosophique
bref les formes idéologie tout ça c'est
la super structure sociale et un super
structure sociale c'est conditionné par
l'infrastructure économique donc
infrastructures économiques les forces
productives et les rapports de
production qui vont engendrer qui vont
déterminer qui vont conditionner la
super structure sociale qui elle même
après va justifier finalement les
rapports de production et donner du sens
à tout cela
donc c'est un renversement par rapport à
notre vision classique nous on va penser
que les hommes politiques le droit va
déterminer tout le reste mais non en
fait
marx nous dit c'est simplement des
facteurs très matérielles puisque ce
sont les techniques les outils les
façons de les utiliser le travail qui
est derrière ça qui va déterminer
bah c'est sûr père structures sociales
et toutes les idéologies et toutes les
organisations sociales qu'on peut avoir
donc c'est un renversement par rapport à
notre vision actuel des choses et c'est
pour cette raison-là qu'il s'agit du
matérialisme historique puisque ce sont
vraiment les éléments très matérielles
qui vont déterminer tout le reste
marx là-dessus s'oppose par exemple un
max weber dans l'éthique protestante et
l'esprit du capitalisme lui a une vision
mais opposé à ce que marc proposant pelé
vraiment les opposer sur ça pour webber
la culture l'idéologie en fait va
déterminer les structures économiques
les protestants
leur façon de penser leur façon de
comprendre le monde va les pousser à
être de très bons entrepreneurs
capitalistes danemark ce deal inverse
les midis ben voilà c'est d'abord le
capitalisme qui va créer une culture du
capital nos plats ya vraiment deux
modèles qui s'opposent j'espère avoir
été clair avec cette vidéo n'hésitez pas
à vous avez toujours les commentaires
pour poser posez vos questions
je vous mets quelques ressources aussi
dans le descriptif et à très bientôt sur
cette chaîne la société
[Musique]
oh